[Music]
welcome back
so i'm really excited about a brand new
lecture series on vector calculus
and how we use vector calculus to derive
and solve
partial differential equations so this
is one of my
absolute favorite fields of all of
mathematics is dynamical systems and
partial differential equations
and essentially these partial
differential equations
express conservation laws
so all partial differential equations
from physics essentially express some
conservation laws
like mass momentum
energy so let's say mass
momentum momentum
and energy okay so for example
uh momentum conservation and a fluid
navy or stokes equations
mass conservation is the continuity
equation
and so on and so forth so uh we're going
to essentially learn
how vector calculus is the language of
partial differential equations
okay so vector calculus
and when i say vector calculus i mean
things like uh
you know the gradient the divergence
and the curl
are essentially the language of how we
describe these conservation laws
so this is the language
for pdes and usually these are taught
kind of separately
when i was learning you know vector
calculus was an interesting thing that
was independent
you know you solved a bunch of surface
integrals and volume integrals
they didn't really tell you why you were
doing that but it turns out that the
reason you want to learn vector calculus
is because that is how
you translate the world the physical
laws of the world
into differential equations that you can
solve and analyze
on pencil and paper on a computer
and this is where you build all of the
intuition for how these things work
okay so i think you know this is a
pretty interesting perspective this is
kind of a holistic
view of not just pdes but pdes
and vector
calculus and so right now i'm just going
to give you a very high level view of
some of the things we're going to talk
about
so we're going to talk about the
intuition for div grad and curl these
vector calculus operations
things like stokes's theorem and gauss's
theorem that allow you to
really do some of these manipulations
you need to write these conservation
laws down as partial differential
equations
and then we're going to start deriving
from scratch the heat equation laplace's
equation
uh mass continuity navy or stokes and
we're going to make
very clear what the assumptions along
the way are are there shock waves is
there some kind of laser
you know pumping energy into my system
all of this uh
we can kind of express in the language
of vector calculus and i'm super excited
to walk you through this uh and so in
general
we think about a kind of a vector
field so um maybe i'll just start with a
good example that i like
which is uh i always think about fluid
flows
so let's think about a fluid flow in the
gulf of mexico
and this is a really terrible gulf of
mexico maybe
i'm from here
cuba is somewhere not on this map
and we assume that there is some
literally a vector
field there is a fluid velocity field at
every point in space
and realistically it's probably changing
in time okay
so there is some vector field we're
going to call this
u of x and t
and when i write it this way usually i'm
going to put an under bar
or an over arrow when i mean a vector
okay
and so literally what i mean by this is
that this is a two-dimensional vector
consisting of the let's say i take one
of these
it has so this is vector u it has a u
component and a v
component a component in the x direction
and a component in the y direction
so this is u of x and y comma t
and little v of x and y comma t
and this little u is different than this
bold u this bold u is a vector
of the x component and the y component
of the velocity
so this is my fluid velocity field
and it is the solution of a partial
differential equation
okay there is some partial differential
equation that represents mass
momentum and energy conservation namely
the navier-stokes equations
and i would have to solve that pde to
get
this vector field okay so this is a
vector field
and i call it a vector field because
literally it's a field of vectors at
every point
x and y and at every instant in time
there is a vector at that location and
it's like a field of vectors like if you
look at a wheat field blowing in the
wind
it shows you the vector field of the
wind
and that's what this is here okay and so
this vector field
is the solution of a partial
differential equation
so in this case maybe i have some pde
which is partial u partial t
so this vector field u and this is bold
u
it's changing in time and its rate of
change in time at every point in space
is going to be given by some generically
nonlinear function
of that vector field okay
good and this might have other partial
derivatives with respect to space it
might have non-linear
product terms and things like that will
derive all of these from scratch
in particular you know these these
equations here
and importantly if this is a real flow
in the gulf of mexico
you know the flow field changes in time
also so i'm going to say and not not
just the flow field changes in time
the dynamics change in time because it's
heated
differently in the summer than in the
winter so there might also be some
time dynamics this might be a function
of the state
and the time and this is
a very general framework i can i can
derive
many different vector and scalar fields
that are the solution the partial
differential equations
for example the temperature in a metal
plate if i hit it with a blow torch in
the middle of that plate
maybe i'll draw that so if i have
some metal plate here and i hit it with
a blow torch
so i have some kind of you know hot
pattern here
and then it gets cooler and cooler out
here
and i want to solve for that temperature
distribution um
let's call that big t
as a function of x and y and
time that is again the solution of a
partial differential equation
in particular this one is pretty easy to
write it's partial
t with respect to time is equal to some
positive constant alpha squared
times the partial squared in x plus the
partial squared n y
which i'm going to very compactly
represent using my vector notation
as the laplacian of the temperature
which is partial squared t
partial x squared plus partial squared t
partial y squared okay so again i can
derive
we're going to derive this heat equation
from scratch
to satisfy this physics here okay namely
you know kind of conservation of heat
energy in this
uh in this plate good
so we're going to show you how to derive
partial differential equations by
encoding these conservation laws
using the language of vector calculus
and we'll be able to
describe tons of physics phenomena from
heat distributions to how an airplane
wing
works and generates lift to how a flow
field evolves
in the gulf of mexico or in some other
fluid flow
environment okay so really really
exciting stuff here
and i want to point out also um
if i have a vector field some solution
of a partial differential equation
u i can also think about the
induced ordinary differential equation
of whether of if i dropped a particle in
this flow field
so imagine that i'm lost at c
so this is me at time 0 i'm x
not and that means x at time 0
y at time 0. and
what we're going to do is we're going to
be able to solve for the future
trajectory
of that point by integrating that
particle through
this vector field so this vector field
this flow field is the solution of my
partial differential equation by navy or
stokes equations
but it also induces a new dynamical
system so if i drop a particle
that particle sees this dynamical system
so i could also
say let me see how i want to write this
i want to say
ddt of x and again this is my bold x
is equal to u of
x and t so this u is a dynamical system
for how a particle x
will float through the gulf of mexico
maybe this is a little oil spill
and i want to track that oil spill and
see where it goes
there's lots of tools for you know
propagating a little gaussian
through this dynamical system that's
something i might want to do on a
computer
to predict where the oil spill is going
to go or maybe someone got
lost at sea off the coastline and swept
away and i've got four hours to rescue
them
where should i search to find those
people
these are real problems that engineers
are working on today
based on the numerical solution of these
problems which is
extremely cool i mean i just love how
many applications and it's tied to all
of my favorite things in dynamical
systems
at the end of the day these pdes set up
dynamical systems for the fluid flow
evolution
and the fluid flow itself sets up a
dynamical system for how particles move
through the fluid flow
good and we could do things like
integrate that particle
through and find x at time
t okay and this might be you know little
x at time t
and little y at time t and i could
integrate
numerically the position of this
particle through that vector field
okay um what else do i want to show you
maybe i'll give you just a very very
quick example
of what grad and div and curl are in
these examples here
okay so if i have a local patch of my
flow field
where things are locally on average
moving away
kind of diverging this
is a location that has a positive
divergence
so the div of u is going to be greater
than
0 at this point and we would say like
div is positive this has a this has a
positive divergence
and so the divergence i'll walk you
through all of these in great detail and
show you exactly how this works
but in some sense the divergence
measures locally how much stuff is
kind of flowing away from that point or
sucking into or converging into that
point
so like your sink is literally a place
where the divergence is less than zero
okay and when you like hit the faucet
and it hits the
metal and it's causing the flow to go
out that's a place where the divergence
is greater than zero
similarly maybe it's hurricane season
and i've got a region over here where my
flow
is going in a big you know big cyclone
it's coming in to the gulf
this would be an area where i would have
a positive
curl okay and so the curl would be
greater than zero and that's given by
this kind of del cross and i'll show you
how these dots and crosses work
this this grad operator is literally a
vector of partial derivatives
and i can take its dot product with u
and v or its cross product
with this uv velocity field uh
good and of course i hope it's obvious
that in three dimensions
this u would have a u v and a w
component for the x
y and z components of the velocity field
and this can generalize to 10 dimensions
or a million dimensions you can have
the heat equation in 5d there's nothing
wrong with that it's just
this equation here okay
the last one i haven't shown you is the
gradient and i really like the gradient
because
the gradient takes a scalar field like a
temperature distribution this is just a
scalar at every point
and it returns a vector field so if i
compute
the gradient of my temperature it will
essentially if i look at the gradient of
my temperature at
this point here it will tell me
in what direction is the temperature
locally increasing the fastest
so it'll essentially establish a vector
field
of where the temperature is increasing
the fastest
so grad of t is a vector
at every point in x and y that says you
know
climb this way if you want to get hotter
faster if you want to
if you want to go to the hot spot as
fast as possible follow the gradient
direction
this is the grad and this is a huge deal
in modern computer optimizations and
machine learning
we do gradient descent or gradient
searches to find
the maximum value of a cost function or
the minimum value
of a loss function and we use stochastic
gradient descent to train all of our
machine learning algorithms
so not all many of our machine learning
algorithms
so again these gradients extend to
million dimensional spaces
where we train models for machine
learning and it all comes back to this
kind of
physical intuition of you know partial
differential equations and conservation
laws
vector calculus i'm super excited to
walk you through this
i'm going to start simple we're going to
start with kind of what these vector
calculus terms mean
we're going to start learning things
like gauss's theorem
and stokes's theorem like gauss's
divergence theorem
we're going to use those to encode these
physical
ideas of conservation of mass momentum
and energy
and derive our partial differential
equations
for real physical systems things like
navy or stokes or the heat equation
or mass continuity this is all coming up
really excited to walk you through this
this is how i wish i had learned
vector calculus and pdes so please you
know stay tuned and keep watching for
more
thank you